>>> WELCOME BACK TO "STATE OF
THE UNION" LIVE FROM UVALDE,
TEXAS.
YEARS OF MASS SHOOTINGS HAVE
DONE LITTLE TO CHANGE THE
DIALOGUE IN WASHINGTON OVER GUN
RESTRICTIONS, BUT MY NEXT GUEST
IS A REPUBLICAN WHO DID CHANGE
HIS MIND ABOUT WHAT SHOULD BE
DONE.
HERE WITH ME NOW IS REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN, AIR FORCE VETERAN
AND PILOT IN THE AIR NATIONAL
GUARD, ADAM KINZINGER OF
ILLINOIS.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING ME THIS
MORNING.
YOU NOW SUPPORT UNIVERSAL
BACKGROUND CHECKS, RED FLAG
LAWS, RAISING THE MINIMUM AGE TO
BUY A GUN, BANNING HIGH-CAPACITY
MAGAZINES.
HOW DID YOUR THINKING EVOLVE?
>> SO, A LOT OF IT HAPPENED
AROUND VEGAS.
I WOKE UP THE MORNING AFTER THE
VEGAS SHOOTING AND, YOU KNOW, WE
HEARD THE AUDIO FROM THAT.
AND I HAD SHOT A BUMP STOCK
BEFORE.
I KNEW THAT WAS A BUMP STOCK.
SO, I CALLED FOR BANNING BUMP
STOCKS.
YOU KNOW, AT THAT POINT, IT'S
LIKE, OKAY, THIS IS GETTING OUT
OF HAND.
WHAT ARE THE THINGS WE WITH DO
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE?
OBVIOUSLY, THERE'S GOING TO BE
SOME FUNDAMENTAL DISAGREEMENT.
IT'S LIKE, WELL, WHY -- WHY
SHOULD SOMEBODY BE ABLE TO BUY A
GUN AT 18?
PARTICULARLY A LONG GUN AT 18,
WHEN AS OF RECENTLY THEY CAN'T
EVEN SMOKE CIGARETTES UNTIL
THEY'RE 21.
IT'S JUST THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
IT'S JUST THAT EVERYBODY IS
SCARED OF INACTION, AND
>> IS THAT THE REASON WHY YOU
THINK SO MANY OF YOUR FELLOW
REPUBLICANS AREN'T WHERE YOU ARE
ON THOSE ISSUES?
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, I'VE TALKED A BUNCH THAT
ARE WHERE I AM BUT THEY WON'T
SAY IT, OR THEY WON'T COME OUT
AND SAY IT BECAUSE, AGAIN, I'VE
EXPERIENCED THIS, WHETHER IT'S
TALKING ABOUT DONALD TRUMP,
JANUARY 6th, OR THE GUNS ISSUE,
IS, YEAH, ONCE YOU MAKE
SOMETHING THAT'S OUTSIDE OF THE
CULTIST POSITION OR OUTSIDE OF
THAT, LIKE, TRIBAL POSITION,
YOU'RE GOING TO GET A BUNCH OF
PEOPLE SAYING YOU'RE CRAZY, IT'S
MY RIGHT, THE SECOND AMENDMENT,
ALTHOUGH WE ALL BELIEVE IN THE
SECOND AMENDMENT, IT'S JUST WE
BELIEVE THERE ARE REASONABLE
THINGS TO DO ABOUT IT.
IF YOU LOOK AT THIS SHOOTING,
YOU LOOK AT BUFFALO, YOU LOOK AT
PARKLAND AND ALL THESE OTHERS,
THERE ARE PEOPLE TAKING THESE
ARs UNDER THE AGE OF 21.
CAN WE STOP ALL OF IT?
NO.
CAN WE MITIGATE IT, CERTAINLY.
AND WE SHOULD BE DOING THAT NOW.
>> GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT SAYS
THIS SHOOTING SHOWS THE NEED FOR
MORE LAWS ADDRESSING MENTAL
HEALTH.
TEXAS SENATOR TED CRUZ WANTS TO
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF DOORS IN
SCHOOLS, PUT ARMED COPS ON
SCHOOL CAMPUSES AND BULLETPROOF
GLASS.
IS THAT ENOUGH TO STOP MASS
SHOOTING IF THE U.S. DOESN'T
ALSO DO SOMETHING ABOUT GUNS?
>> I ULTIMATELY THINK IT'S A
HEART ISSUE BECAUSE PEOPLE HAVE
TO MAKE A DECISION TO GO AND DO
A MASS SHOOTING.
BUT BASICALLY TURNING SCHOOLS
INTO MILITARY CAMPS, IF WE THINK
THAT'S GOING TO BE THE ANSWER,
EVEN IF IT DOES WORK, WHICH IT
WON'T, BUT EVEN IF IT DOES,
THAT'S NOT THE KIND OF COUNTRY I
WANT TO LIVE IN.
I'VE GOT A KID THAT'S 4 MONTHS
OLD AND WILL BE GOING TO SCHOOL
SOMEDAY.
I DON'T WANT HIM TO HAVE A
MILITARY I.D. TO GET INTO AN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
THESE POLITICIANS THAT ARE
SCARED TO DEATH TO TALK ABOUT
THE GUN ISSUE, THEY KNOW THAT
THIS IS AN ISSUE, BUT THEY'RE
SCARED TO TALK ABOUT IT SO THEY
LAUNCH INTO THIS THING ABOUT
MENTAL HEALTH.
WE ALL AGREE THAT MENTAL HEALTH
IS A PROBLEM.
FIRST OFF, I'D ASK HAVE THEY
ACTUALLY PUT ANY MORE MONEY INTO
MENTAL HEALTH, PEOPLE LIKE TED
CRUZ, HIGHLY DOUBT IT.
BUT, SECONDARILY, AT THE SAME
TIME, WHY IS AN 18-YEAR-OLD
BUYING AN AR?
SO, IT'S NOT AN IF OR THAT.
THERE'S ALWAYS THE OLD SAYING
TOO ABOUT THE WAY TO STOP A BAD
GUY WITH A GUN IS A GOOD GUY
WITH A GUN.
TYPICALLY I AGREE.
BUT THERE ARE THERE WERE 150
GOOD GUYS WITH GUNS AT THIS
SHOOTING WHO DIDN'T DO ANYTHING
UNTIL BASICALLY BORDER PATROL
S.W.A.T. SHOWED UP.
WE'VE GOT TO TAKE HANDLE OF
THIS, THIS IS INSANE.
>> CONGRESSMAN, YOU DO STILL
OPPOSE A BAN ON THE KIND OF
ASSAULT WEAPONS THAT WERE USED
IN THIS SHOOTING.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN WHY PRIVATE
CITIZENS NEED WEAPONS OF WAR?
>> LOOK, I HAVE OPPOSED A BAN,
YOU KNOW, FAIRLY RECENTLY.
I THINK I'M OPEN TO A BAN NOW.
IT'S GOING TO DEPEND ON WHAT IT
LOOKS LIKE BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT
OF NUANCES ON WHAT CONSTITUTES
CERTAIN THINGS.
BUT I'M GETTING TO THE POINT
WHERE I HAVE TO WONDER MAYBE
SOMEBODY TO OWN ONE, MAYBE YOU
NEED AN EXTRA LICENSE, MAYBE YOU
NEED EXTRA TRAINING.
SO THE QUESTION IS, IS IT A BAN
VERSUS ADDITIONAL CERTIFICATION?
99.9% OF PEOPLE THAT OWN ARs, WE
ALL KNOW ARE NOT GOING TO WALK
INTO A SCHOOL AND DO THIS.
BUT THE PROBLEM IS FOR THOSE
THAT SUPPORT THE SECOND
AMENDMENT LIKE ME, WE HAVE TO BE
COMING TO THE TABLE WITH WAYS TO
MITIGATE 18-YEAR-OLDS BUYING
THESE GUNS AND WALKING INTO
SCHOOLS.
MY SIDE'S NOT DOING THAT.
MY SIDE'S NOT COMING FORWARD
WITH REASONABLE WAYS TO DEFEND
AN AMENDMENT THAT WE THINK IS
VERY IMPORTANT.
AND SO I'M LOOKING AT THIS
GOING, FINE, IF PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO PUT FORWARD SOLUTIONS ABOUT
CERTIFYING MAYBE WHO CAN BUY AN
ASSAULT WEAPON, I'M CERTAINLY
OPEN TO THAT.
>> SO THAT IS ANOTHER CHANGE, IT
SOUNDS LIKE, YOU'RE WILLING TO
MAKE.
CONGRESSMAN, I WANT TO TURN TO
THE TOPIC OF JANUARY 6th.
YOU ARE OF COURSE A MEMBER OF
THAT COMMITTEE, THE HOUSE
REPUBLICAN LEADER, KEVIN
McCARTHY SAYS HE WILL NOT COMPLY
WITH THE COMMITTEE'S SUBPOENA TO
INTERVIEW HIM AS IT CURRENTLY
STANDS.
ARE YOU CONSIDERING HOLDING THE
SITTING HOUSE MINORITY LEADER IN
CONTEMPT OF CONGRESS?
>> YOU KNOW, THAT'S A BIG DEAL.
OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE THINGS WE
CAN DO INCLUDING, YOU KNOW,
WHETHER IT'S WITH ETHICS OR
OTHER THINGS.
TRUST ME, EVERY DAY WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WHAT TO DO WHEN
THESE MEMBERS, IF THESE MEMBERS
DON'T COMPLY WITH THE SUBPOENA.
SO, WE'LL SEE.
BUT I'M GOING TO TELL YOU,
ULTIMATELY, IT SAYS WAY MORE
ABOUT HIM THAN US IF HE DOESN'T
COME IN.
BECAUSE, LOOK, HE HAS
INFORMATION, WE WANT TO TALK TO
HIM.
THIS IS THE HOUSE THAT HE WANTS
TO BE THE SPEAKER OF, BY THE
WAY, AND HE'S SAYING YOU DON'T
HAVE A RIGHT -- LOOK, I'M NOT
GOING TO BE HERE NEXT YEAR IN
CONGRESS, BUT I GUARANTEE IF HE
IS SPEAKER, THERE ARE GOING TO
BE PEOPLE WHO ARE, LIKE, WAIT,
YOU DIDN'T EVEN BOTHER TO COMPLY
WITH A SUBPOENA.
KEVIN McCARTHY HAS NO RESPECT
FOR THE INSTITUTION, FOR THE
PROCESS.
HE JUST WANTS TO BE POWERFUL.
AND IT'S NOT THROUGH NORMAL
MEANS, IT'S REALLY KISSING